my job is to spread the gospel to let
people know what Jesus has done for me
Kanye West is getting candid about
religion music and sex in a new
interview with Apple musics beats one
the rapper opened up to Zane Lowe about
the pretty big ask he made of those
close to him while working on his ninth
studio album Jesus is king we're talking
fasting and no sex people you know there
was times where I was asking people to
fast doing the album
this is gonna be radical when I'm about
to say I know this is we can look at it
edit this time was where I was asking
people to not have premarital sex while
they were working on the album why you
might ask
a good question Kanye said he believed
it would bring focus to the project
families are pray together stay together
when people pray together and fast
together mm-hmm the the power is is
increased but fans were left hanging at
cuz when the clock turned to Friday the
album didn't drop Twitter exploded just
after midnight on the east coast when
Kanye's hotly anticipated album which
was really truly no seriously supposed
to drop @midnight didn't actually drop
@midnight
it wasn't until over an hour after the
fact that Kanye explained that the album
still needed work and that he was busy
fixing it quote we are not going to
sleep until this album is out so fasting
no sex and no sleep sounds fun and how's
this for awkward earlier in the day
Kanye stopped by Jimmy Kimmel Live which
was filming in New York this week to
promote Jesus's King and he doubled down
on his promise that the music would drop
at midnight when is this album coming
out is it coming out tomorrow it's gonna
be dropping 12 the 12 a.m.
right now it is available or it's out
now yeah yeah so oopsie
there is a little silver lining here
while fans waited for new music they
also got to see this super cute video of
Kanye's daughter North dancing in front
of a screen showing footage of him from
his upcoming documentary also titled
Jesus's King I want to say I love the
fact that my daughter wants to go to
church and her she has such a positive
thought association to go into church
because it's outside of the tradition of
four walls and outside of the shoes one
thing is clear
Kanye is now focused on his spirituality
now that God has called me enough I now
have given my life to Jesus Christ and I
work for God we're in complete service
to God Kanye also has a Sunday service
themed album Jesus is born that is due
out this Christmas I'm a son now son of
God I'm free all right
the album is finally out now it dropped
while we were filming this so I'm gonna
go take the rest of this day and listen
and learn from the gospel of Kanye stick
with et for all the latest on Kanye
until next time I'm Hallie Stephens bye
for now
[Music]